男になれな男の愛というのは守るという
ことだベタベタして好きだ好きだというの
が愛やないぞ自分を守り家庭を守り国を
守るこれが男の仕事や1番基本は種族保存
子供を作れだ
から強くなれ弱いやつは守れん女に負け
たらあかん
ぞ今はもう男の方が女になりたいって言い
出すよね女は楽な気がするんやねわがまま
言っても許される女はわがままを言うそれ
を許すのが男の仕事やないか
[音楽]
な女
を下に見るだけの強さがないといかん
よそれがね子供に響いてくるよ子供は自分
が守られんといかん弱いんだからで守るの
はお父さんの仕事だもしお父さんが弱いと
子供は不安定になる精神的にも肉体的にも
昔あの東校拒否や飛行を直しとる時にうち
にやってくる頼みに来る親家庭全部か電界
やったでお父さんが弱いまたはお母さんが
強すぎるあるいは母子家庭だでお父さんの
存在が薄いと子供は不安定になる不安定だ
と進歩しないそうやねねだからまず子供を
安定させる父親の仕事やこれは父親が
強ければ子供は勝手に安定するええな強く
なれこれが男の仕事一番大事なこと
やうちの孫だ沖縄でガやっとる時になんや
かやこうくっついてきた話を聞きたがるで
その時にお前は男なんだから妹も一緒に来
とってな妹やお母さんを将来守らんといか
んだから強くならんといかんのやぞ言った
わかりましたちゃんと守ります言って
ね子供やからその妹のとろに行って将来俺
がお前を守ってやるって言いに行ったそし
たらそん時ちょうどもっと大きい女の子と
2人でおってな殴られちまって何言ってん
の言ってそしたらうわーっと泣いてきてな
守ると言ったら殴られましたっていうそう
やろってあれが女
だだけどあの女をお前が守らんといかんの
だ頑張って強くなることや言ったら分かり
ました言ってまたありきっちまってねこれ
が男
ない目的ができるんよね男としての
男の子はみんな男になりたいんやそれが
途中でダメになっちゃうしごかれんもんで
弱くなっちまってもう男嫌だになっ
ちまう男はうんとごかれろ
[音楽]
なM